and for some perspective on all this we
turn to the Washington Post
Ambra Philip she writes about politics
for the fix amber good morning Martin
let's start with the president's alleged
comments coming at a time when lawmakers
are trying to work out a deal on
immigration reform what what is it how
does this affect back do you think it's
not clear so to one degree Congress is
really used to the president distracting
them but it doesn't usually cause an
international incident right but they've
kind of been able to compartmentalize
some of the what the president says and
say okay we're gonna work around you to
try to get tax reform done but this is
so high-profile and and it just throws a
bomb into all this really explosive
already immigration debate that it's
possible both sides retreat to their
corners and and make compromise a lot
less likely and they weren't anywhere
close to compromise even before it was
released the president allegedly said
this politically how did this play with
the president's base amber we know
Republican senators like Tim Scott and
Lindsey Graham are effectively
confirming some of the comments
President made but what about the people
that support the president yeah so it's
hard to answer that without any public
polling but I can tell you that the the
media that kind of supports the
president and a lot of the base listens
to that media like Sean Hannity and
Tucker Carlson on Fox News are defending
the president right off the bat they're
saying you know what this is our
president getting tough on immigration
this is exactly what we want them to
hear way to stand up to those guys in
Washington who are too politically
correct so it is entirely possible that
there is no fallout from the president's
pace for this on the whole immigration
question I want to talk about the
dreamers issue and and trying to get a
deal that there's a deadline that that
the on March 5th that's set by the
president I mean how likely is a deal at
this point there's such a good question
this is one of those things where
everyone in Washington agrees something
needs to get done but they can't figure
out how to do it there's two main
reasons for that one is the president's
wall Democrats tell me if he demands
money for his border wall they're out it
is just such a symbol of everything
they despise about the president they
cannot negotiate on that there's also a
sizable chunk of Republicans on the
right who are okay not protecting
dreamers they see it as amnesty people
like Steve King in Iowa and when you put
those together you don't have a majority
of Congress to agree to a deal this is
not just about immigration either we're
talking about keeping the government up
and running is the government going to
shut down Enver oh my gosh I'm trying to
figure that out I feel like it's like
50/50 at this point and that's my answer
to that is Congress has two options they
can somehow pass a long-term budget that
has eluded them for since September they
could agree on just a short-term budget
to kick the can down the road for a
couple months right even that with all
the news and all the dramas happen this
week could be difficult
it's just Democrats are debating do we
try to seize this moment or President
Trump they feel this week to demand
there's protections for dreamers because
it's Republicans they're calculating who
would be blamed for a shutdown because
they control all of Washington you
mentioned all the drama that's happened
this week with all that drama it's hard
to believe it was way back on Tuesday
that Steve Benin stepped down from
Breitbart news it was a thousand years
ago what what what do you what's the
impact do you think of that on the whole
right wing movement that he was trying
to propel yeah yeah you're exactly right
so when Steve Bannon was it Breitbart
and had the ear the president he was
planning to unseat or at least challenge
almost every single Senate Republican
incumbent up for election this year that
is now thrown completely in doubt he
really doesn't have a platform to do
that and and we saw as soon as Steve
Bannon left some of the right-wing
challengers like in Arizona and Nevada
and Wisconsin stepped away from Steve
Bannon a little bit because they feel
like when given the choice well if it's
Bannon or Trump yeah voters are going to
want me to side with Trump speaking of
the other things that happen this week
we had heard some rumors that Robert
Muller may actually interview President
Trump where do things stand on that
front
terms of the investigation yeah so the
Washington Post reported that in
december robert molars lawyers went to
trump's lawyers and said we think we
want to interview the president let's
start talking about terms and there's so
much negotiations that go into getting a
president to sit down with an ongoing
investigation
president Trump earlier this year had
suggested or excuse me said outright 100
percent was his comment I would testify
under oath saying there's no collusion
he backed away from that this week he he
said in press conferences you know I I
don't know if I gonna testify because
there isn't an in collusion and that
throws into doubt the whole negotiation
so we'll see if Muller can get the
president to sit down with him
throws into doubt could be the banner
headline from this very member Phillips
with The Washington Post thanks amber